[Música]
buenas tardes mi historia arranca allá
por el 2008 yo con un grupo de amigos
organizaba un evento de cultura popular
y estábamos viendo que íbamos a hacer
para la quinta edición empezamos a
explorar un poco que era la oferta de
contenido que podíamos encontrar en la
ciudad y así me encontré aume tope con
la comunidad de desarrolladores de
videojuegos santafesinas
en realidad yo ya sabía de la existencia
de este este colectivo este grupo porque
ya en
los pasillos de la facultad había visto
algunos afiches que
e invitaban a reuniones en distintas
fechas
siempre por hecho porque no encontraba
la manera de ir o me olvidaba último
momento o siempre tenía algo organizado
me contacte con uno de los coordinadores
de esta comunidad y me dijo mira ahora
en un par de días se está haciendo un
ciclo de charlas en el foro de la
universidad venía arreglamos a ver cómo
hacemos en el evento
yo fui escuché un poquito de qué se
trataba la industria local yo todo esto
21 años siendo la facultad nada que ver
y me entero que para fin de año estaban
organizando un viaje a un evento que yo
no conocí hasta el momento ese era la
exposición de videojuegos argentina la
eba
yo super caradura agarre y me sume al
viaje porque justo ese fin de semana yo
estaba viajando para ir a representar a
la universidad en el mundial de
programación en la en la uba
me saqué hotel en el mismo lugar donde
estaban parando de ellos terminé de
participar me tengo entrena microcentro
fui a parar con ellos salimos a tomar
algo y al otro día fuimos a la eba
la verdad que yo estaba esperando un
evento
modesto estaba esperando un evento más
cotidiano pero la verdad es que cuando
llegué me impactó el evento era en el
centro cultural san martín estaba lleno
de gente hay un montón de stands había
coros y uno o dos salones de charlas y
empecé a recorrer un poquito que lo que
se estaba haciendo lo cierto que había
unos stands
me acuerdo patente que en un momento me
impactó de uno de los stands que hay un
cartucho de nintendo ds con su cajita y
yo me quedé mirándolo levantó la mirada
y le digo al que está atendido están
este juego que cuando ustedes que lo
comercializan o que particiaron algo me
dicen no nosotros lo desarrollamos esto
es un evento de desarrollo
claro por más que ya me habían contado
de la industria en mi cabeza los
videojuegos lo hacían los alienígenas y
los japoneses no había gente normal
haciendo viejos no había gente que vivir
a hacer videojuegos
en ese momento la pregunta fue
totalmente estúpida pero me cambio me
hizo un clic en la cabeza
sin mucha más pena ni gloria termino mi
evh a nos volvimos a santafé y empecé a
interesar un poquito más con la
comunidad de desarrollo de videojuegos
más o menos a los meses me contacta este
coordinador de la comunidad y me comenta
que había una oportunidad a través de la
asociación de desarrolladores
videojuegos la asociación que organizaba
este evento al que había ido
para un desafío de mezclar los juegos
hacer un juego y sacar un prototipo y
que eso más una posibilidad de un fondo
para emprendedores que había dando
vuelta era una excusa para formar un
estudio nuevo que se conocía alguien que
supiera programar en flash
de vuelta haciendo totalmente caradura
le agarró digo mira la verdad yo sé
programar hice leer sin tener un poquito
de paciencia me hago más o menos y
aprendo flash y así es como esta persona
me presenta andrés miranda quienes hoy
en día todavía mi socio y allá por
febrero del 2009 fundamos nuestro
nuestro estudio durante todo ese año
trabajamos nuestro primer juego
muy sabiendo pocas cosas pero
preguntando mucho la comunidad a través
del foro a través de la asociación
para fin de 2009 volvimos a ir a la eba
prestaba ya no era un paracaidista era
tenía y donde estaba ahora yo ya iba con
un stand con la comunidad presentando mi
juego
realmente me volvía aún más impactado
estábamos en la universidad de belgrano
una cosa hermosa y la gente venía me
preguntaba y me encontraba con gente que
era un espejo de un año antes que venía
bch y este juego qué onda
de ahí
conseguimos varios contactos y empezamos
a sacar nuestros primeros clientes de
buenos aires- haciendo de tercerización
de trabajo
de esta tercerización del trabajo
uno de los estudios que lamentablemente
no existe más se llamaba qb9 nos
contactan y nos dicen che
vamos a hacer un proyecto para una marca
de ladrillos y muñequitos muy conocida
europea muy muy conocida vamos a los
proyectos juntos elaboramos con ellos
esos proyectos y a los meses nos
contactan de vuelta y dicen che nosotros
con esta gente estamos haciendo juegos
grandes juegos medianos y juegos
pequeños los juegos pequeños a nosotros
por la infraestructura que tenemos no
nos rinden monetariamente se los
tercerizados a ustedes más que nada para
quedar bien con esta marca pero la
verdad es un garrón
nos gustaría presentarles esta marca
europea para que sea su cliente ya que
conseguimos nuestras primeras
exportaciones
a todo esto nosotros ya veníamos
trabajando acá en la ciudad en la
provincia generando charlas generando
generando espacios de discusión trayendo
gente a que dé a que dé talleres y
también trabajando con el gobierno
provincial para pelear desde nuestro
humilde espacio políticas públicas para
poder hacer crecer la industria
así fue como logramos que en el 2011
la exposición de videojuegos argentina
está de buenos aires argentina en
realidad fueran patrocinados por el
gobierno de la provincia y que en el
2012 no sólo hay una misión comercial de
san francisco eeuu de parte de argentina
sino que también nos acompañó la
provincia y fuimos empresas santafesinas
como comitiva dai sacamos nuestro
segundo gran cliente un canal de dibujos
animados también muy conocidos
nosotros ya estábamos exportando
seguíamos laburando acá
explicando traíamos gente a que venga a
probar cosas ayudamos con el juego
hacíamos testeos
y cada vez que contábamos que estábamos
haciendo este tipo de trabajo
familiares amigos allegados
sin entender por ahí la perspectiva que
uno tenía venía y te decían he vuelto
enfoca un poquito en tu emprendimiento
porque no para ser un poquito más cargo
de lo tuyo que la verdad tenía que
prestar la atención me parece que estás
habiendo giles ok
y la para que nosotros no lo veíamos así
pues ya estábamos acostumbrados a que
así se venía dando la dinámica cuando
nosotros entramos nosotros arrancamos
simplemente venimos replicando lo que ya
estaba todo venía bárbaro conseguimos
otro cliente grande ahora un canal de
dibujos animados más grande todavía pero
desde sucede latinoamericana
y un día
de golpe todo cambio no tan de golpe en
realidad pero si se sintió
con uno de los clientes un proyecto
largo salió mal y se perdió esta empresa
europea de ladrillos cambió su política
de contratación decidió de hacer muchos
proyectos chiquitos hacer muy pocos
puntuales grandes y claramente nosotros
hagamos un estudio pequeño de argentina
que no los podíamos cubrir y ese cliente
que trajimos de eeuu ese canal de
dibujos animados
empezó a hacer un cambio interno de
mover gente y todos los contactos que
nosotros teníamos no estaban más en la
organización y no teníamos mails que nos
respondan
fueron unos años muy complicados
realmente no lográbamos cerrar proyectos
en el ínterin de todo eso nuestros
socios se va quedamos solamente con
andrés
y en este momento nosotros seguíamos
trabajando desde la asociación seguíamos
trabajando en dar cursos seguíamos
trabajando en hacer las jornadas de
desarrollo de videojuegos santafesino
que se hacían en este mismo escenario
pero en ese momento
cuando nosotros trabajábamos y
trabajábamos para salir adelante y no
podíamos salir adelante a ningún lado ya
no eran los allegados los que decían
déjate de [ __ ] ahora será yo el que me
decía a mí mismo
déjate de [ __ ] deja de entrenar a tu
competencia estás avivando giles
en un momento
también de vuelta voy a decir de golpe
pero no fue golpe realmente fue mucho
trabajo llegar a ese punto
los proyectos empezaron a salir de
vuelta
ese hueco que tuvimos de trabajo lo
pudimos sobrevivir porque había otros
estudios en la ciudad y en la provincia
que por ahí nos podían tirar un hueso
nos podían tirar un proyecto con el cual
tal vez ese mes no ganábamos plata pero
en vez de perder 10 perdíamos 2
o ganábamos 4
y eso nos permitió sobrevivir hasta que
empezaron a salir de vuelta de los
proyectos pero el problema también
cuando salieron los proyectos es que
nosotros no sabíamos replegado éramos un
estudio más pequeño todavía que antes
éramos menos gente
y al mismo tiempo como ya nos habíamos
quemado con listeria la vaca llorábamos
le teníamos mucho miedo a volver a
crecer a volver a incorporar gente pues
no sabíamos cuándo iba a durar y
justamente por poder tener otros
estudios a los cuales nosotros sabíamos
que sabían trabajar porque los habíamos
ayudado a conseguir capacitaciones
porque cada vez que nosotros habíamos
aprendido a hacer algo enseguida se los
replicamos y al mismo tiempo que se
cultivaron con nosotros nos podíamos
apoyar en esos estudios para salir
adelante para poder aumentar
temporariamente nuestra capacidad de
producción para buscar también talentos
complementarios que nosotros en nuestro
estudio no teníamos y tal vez hasta el
día de hoy no tenemos
desde enero de este año me desenvuelvo
como presidente de adba de la asociación
de desarrolladores de videojuegos
argentinas
esta asociación que organiza ese evento
que allá por el 2008 me cambió la forma
de ver la vida es una asociación de
gente que
trabaja y paga una cuota y pone su
tiempo para trabajar gratis por el otro
no es casual o por lo menos yo no lo veo
casual que según los datos del
observatorio de videojuegos de la
universidad rafael a
en cada lugar donde hay un caudillo
donde hay un empresario que toma la
posta y trabaja por la industria local
es donde los números vemos que crecen
más rápido donde la industria que sea
más rápido año año
yo creo
qué
no fue original de mí no nació de mí yo
no tomé la decisión de tomar esta
actitud para con mis colegas de la
industria yo creo que me vino impuesta
yo creo que me encontré con que las
cosas ya eran así y de alguna manera yo
lo seguí haciendo
y la gente que viene detrás nuestro
vemos que también lo hace esta actitud
se contagia esta actitud no queda en uno
y es sumamente productiva yo les
recomiendo o les deseo que cada uno en
su
también en su industria o en su ámbito
de laburo pueda ver cómo puede
desbordarse cómo puede compartir con el
otro cómo puede trabajar
colaborativamente
porque es una actitud que enseguida
vuelve
me parece que tal vez yo estoy hablando
desde una posición
distinta porque estoy en una industria
donde nuestros veteranos apenas pasan
los 60 años porque estoy en una
industria donde tal vez todavía hay
demasiado trabajo y no tenemos que estar
matando no soportando nos la cabeza para
salir a buscar un cliente y una
industria donde todos los años se
generan nuevos recursos humanos y más
allá de los problemas que tenemos de
recursos humanos todavía nos sentimos la
necesidad de ir a depredar la empresa
del otro
tal vez por eso en nuestra industria
este modelo es exitoso la verdad no lo
sé yo sólo sé que voy a seguir con esta
actitud mientras pueda porque más allá
de todo me parece que en esta historia
el primer gil que llevaron fui yo
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]